I have no idea what it is it's not the
moon and it's not a star says the
Curious Montana resident who shot this
video from his driveway on Wednesday the
Pentagon says this is a Chinese
surveillance balloon
it seems so Brazen and just so
insane to me that that anyone would even
attempt to just push a balloon over the
sky because to me it was just like this
thing is so visible the Pentagon says
shooting down the balloon could put
lives at risk on the ground and it's not
a significant threat from an intelligent
standpoint I think that it would be
um ridiculous if the government didn't
retrieve it
um I mean obviously I think that's the
first course of action is to get it out
of the sky through whatever means they
need to
house Speaker Kevin McCarthy tweeted
China's Brazen disregard for U.S
sovereignty is a destabilizing action
that must be addressed the spokeswoman
for the Chinese foreign Ministry says
she hopes the superpowers can resolve
this matter calmly
I would like to stress that before it
becomes clear what happened any
deliberate speculation where hyping up
will now help handling the matter
the surveillance balloon's arrival
coincides with U.S Secretary of State
Anthony blinken's visit to Beijing next
week
tensions have been rising on the status
of Taiwan and the theft of intellectual
property
a pentagon official says this isn't the
first time China has launched a spy
balloon but this one has remained in
American airspace longer
Natasha gname Al Jazeera